quando então vamos falar um chute na
área inflamada em área de encostas que
efetivamente sobre a condição do viva a
partir do escrito o e mata desta
aplicação é o pensamento é um todo a
nossa missão enquanto espécie é um caso
difícil de fazer a pontes mais vão ver
que eu não só nas ciências diferenças
tem trazido grandes benefícios para a
sociedade
dentro das ciências forenses santa luzia
uma das que mais têm crescido na última
década porque tem contribuído se lamente
parados alguns casos cana criminais e
sobretudo têm menor benefício social
através da resolução de identificar as
pessoas então o que é que nós fazemos
entre poesia florença dizemos ganhar a
sua voz seja identificadas as pessoas
com base em fragmentos ósseos senhoras
cremados em corpos em vários estados da
competição
para isso temos que saber aqui da
cápsula tinha quando morreu que é uma
das grandes dificuldades do dia a frança
atual sobretudo para os rendimentos mais
idosos
dizemos o corpo porque venceu o homem ou
mulher
dizemos com a origem geográfica provável
através das características sociais ias
fazemos uma com somos lógica
designadamente está estruturado talendo
quem era
respondendo também uma questão básica
que é como eu isso tem a ver com a causa
e circunstância da morte quando aos mais
traumáticas afetas poços que ficam perto
de órgãos vitais como é o caso do crânio
nós podemos ser pretorius motivamente a
causa da morte
outra questão que respondemos é a quanto
tempo morreu quando morreu
ou seja os ossos podem responder a
questões fundamentais
a secção o cain o como eo quanto os
ossos contou histórias não contam a
história toda
mas aqui o que conta é é verdadeiro ou
seja os ossos não mentem para os
conteúdos destas questões temos que
fazer investigação se identificar e
aplicar a aparecer tecnologias para isso
contamos com equipas interdisciplinares
que trabalham em várias áreas e também
com correções de escolher se
identificados são particularmente
importantes corpos doados à ciência
corpos abandonados em cemitérios que
estão completamente identificados e que
nós estudamos exaustivamente para
conseguir desenvolver melhores
metodologias para responder àquelas
questões básicas do cae do quadro e do
antes por exemplo agora mesmo estamos a
construir uma coleção do século 21
pessoas todas morreram no século 21 que
é constituída fundamentalmente por
indivíduos idosos porque um dos grandes
problemas que temos é efetivamente
primariedade a morte muitas pessoas mais
velhas
então vamos imaginar um caso diferença
anglo em braga que toda a identificação
todo ter uma diferença trabalha num
começa no campo
no local um corpo é descoberto no local
smhadu as questões estão há quanto tempo
está no total nos ossos foram anuncidas
texto o caldo de posição inicial que por
exemplo estamos a ver um crânio uma vala
comum que está como é difícil de sair de
um projeto que toda identificação tem
que ser feito obrigatoriamente nunca
alto que esse trabalho vai se destruído
durante o processo de exumação
este é um caso da guerra civil espanhola
cujas falas como estão a ser trabalhados
agora desde o ano 2000 e como vive em
águas canção dos coretos mostra-nos que
foi retirado à pressa e de qualquer
maneira
ao todo mundo que veio logo a inicia uma
situação ilegal
usando falsos frente sem ter o menor
prince a ela temia isso não são pedras
são os corpos das vértebras de um bebê
recém-nascido e por isso só digo
internados e conseguem detetar um treino
restos desta dimensão
outra questão que temos que resolver é
quando os indivíduos estão presentes o
que é particularmente difícil quando
estamos em valas comuns como desse tipo
em que temos que separar os lotes que
vem todos misturados por uma ter lhe
dado o tipo de osso para depois
conseguir fazer em visualização do
documento a do emf do belém vencer não
lembrar que trabalhamos com corpos em
vários estados da preservação em que
pode acontecer que o craque esteja
cruzado a determinados modificadas e
horários santo unificado e depois agora
vamos ver um bocadinho melhor começa a
responder esta questão de quem é
temos que devolver a identidade
independentemente do estado de
preservação da bacia os ossos da bacia
são os melhores para afirmar o sexo dos
adultos
ali temos um osso feminino ea direita
algumas cup no nas crianças as
tentativas da idade é bastante acredita
onde temos então uma etapa óssea que é
nada por exemplo pelos ossos do crânio
pelos ossos do esqueleto pós camiã no
que nos permite poder dizer não sei na
síria um bebê há poucos meses uma
criança coletivamente mais velha
nós definitivamente os melhores pelo
menos tratar a invasão à morte são os
dentes que são efetivamente as nossas
caixas negras têm um esmalte que o
material mais duro do corpo humano
nos adultos a situação é muito mais
complicada porque conhecemos mau
investimento do esqueleto temos zonas
particularmente boas como a bacia que
estamos vendo uma moça da cia o crânio é
muito falível
ou seja é tido como o evento
o mais importante para a estimativa de
dólar do status quo é a origem
geográfica é nada pelas características
faciais aqui está em dois indivíduos de
origem africana em pó dem por exemplo
ver a projeção anterior da fácil e
estrutura é feita através do cumprimento
dos ossos longos sendo melhor deus maior
dos ossos longos que é ofender com essas
características conseguimos um perfil
biológico que nunca vai conseguir
identificar uma pessoa mas vai conseguir
dizer a fazer uma fusão ou seja os
agentes tagem desaparecidos da polícia
judiciária que são públicas estão nos
sites e fazemos a contratação do nosso
resultado com as suas duas filhas até
conseguirmos ter um fio de loja
confiança a partir desse momento para se
passarmos para os fatores de
individualização com características
únicas que existem num determinado
indivíduo que não existe mais nenhum
assim como a dois indivíduos livres e
iguais também não há dois coletes iguais
é que nós temos que dizer é porque
acredita a é diferente do b e porque
acreditem eu escrevi por ter só
indivíduo x e não pode pertencer a mais
num convento o santos troca turísticas
de cada uma delas as situações anos nós
patológicas cantuta em menor potencial
tem aquela identificação
outra característica que ajuda na
identificação os sites frontais que são
bonitos
é como se fossem impressões digitais e
desde que exista um raio x da vítima em
vida a sobreposição craniofacial permite
fazer a atribuição de identidade
quanto a outras técnicas como por
exemplo surtou era imagem da vítima
o crânio da suposta vítima permitidos
sobretudo fazer exclusões não pode
permitir uma identificação a 100 por
cento à mesma coisa relativamente à
aproximação inicial que permite ter uma
imagem da vítima mas nunca uma imagem
real vai permitir avivar a memória mas
não nunca podemos chegar a todos os
hospitais quer dizer que nem sempre
conseguimos devolver o corpo à família
que é o caso um ficamos que muitos casos
com identidades presumida agenda
contendo anos e investigará em homicídio
caso nós dizemos por isso simplesmente
não é como é que nós vimos a causa da
morte
através da análise de josué traumáticas
podemos identificar o tipo de usar um
instrumento a arma foi baleado
quarta escola a trajetória do projétil
raramente podemos falar de tecnologia
médica ao local mas quando há uma
discussão nós conseguimos provar que foi
homicídio como por exemplo neste caso o
mesmo ou ainda nesta também neste
identificarmos o instrumento foi muito
utilizado para fazer os cortes neste
caso de desmembramento estudo deve ser
muita investigação na área da via única
das regiões na atenção nos sinais de
hemorragia continuou seco na cronologia
das ilusões ou seja saber a quanto tempo
até aquela os dois foram feitas e também
uma determinação da sequência das lesões
que atingiram 1 terminado em vivido hoje
em magia tarde permitindo avançar
significativamente na medida em que os
primeiros fazer construções que estavam
extraordinário momento fragmentados
aqui por exemplo foi uma vítima teve os
braços amputados e as várias tentativas
permitiram identificar um instrumento
utilizado para amputar as mãos
a migros pia e depois amigos pia
permitem nos dizer se os cortes foram
feitos
ué na altura da morte depois da morte e
porque instrumento o que nos leva a
poder fazer na construção das cenas
podemos dizer o henrique começaram as
razões na parte superior do corpo na
partida anterior
hum e microscopia que dizemos que uma
célula manual que provocou toda saque
aos cortes aqui um exemplo de uma
fratura muito sorteio numa tíbia que nos
mostra que resultou numa queda vertical
com a tragédia
sobre os pés e agora alguma questão há
quanto tempo eu o tempo do pv da morte é
particularmente difícil terminar às
outras numa interpretação holística em
que até por exemplo adotar nica free
ansa em tecnologia frança e de
composição intermédica mostras agora
dois casos e este é um caso que motiva
instituto nacional de neurociência
diferença onde estão tendo um corpo
queimado em uma kombi estava complicada
para o na zona das pernas
aqui nós conseguimos fazer é identificar
a menina através de fragmentos ósseos
convém aqui e interpretar o que
aconteceu para ter acontecido uma
combustão lenta e prolongada como esta
para terminar num caso em que será
avaliar este ano um país africano que é
de fugir enquanto isto humanitários
valas comuns constam 19 vítimas mortas e
localmente em que nós contribuímos
diretamente para ele ficar efetivas e
para documentário as violações de
direitos humanos que têm como podem ver
são muitas mas é o trabalho da
tecnologia e de outros projetos
diferentes que nos permita documentário
a causa da morte e as violações e
agressões que existiram antes da morte
durante o período estiveram aprisionados
essas situações do trabalho e emprego
a humanidade quer ainda acho que massa
tem sido para o pagamento de
gratificados por quem efetivamente é um
reconhecimento do nosso trabalho que faz
com que sejamos cada vez mais chamados
para intervir em situações deste tipo e
que nos motiva a fazer cada vez mais
investigação para resolver situações
como estas em que por exemplo neste país
africano já achavam impossível alguma
vez vir a ter os corpos dos seus
familiares e e virando ver os
responsáveis por essas situações presos
e incriminados é porque estavam com que
eu encontrar provas para as provas
efetivamente estamos quatro já scott as
provas estão nos nossos mares de cristo
o pagamento que uma rigorosa
documentação de tudo o que aconteceu
leva a que os responsáveis dos
criminosos que jorge praticamente preso
e que as famílias possam finalmente
fazer o luto e ter os corpos dos seus
familiares consigo
são exceções nos dizemos que o espírito
poderia ter falar também dos desastres
massa como por exemplo quedas de avião
como o sexto tempo morre mas são 100
pessoas têm tanto aos fãs conseguiram
fazer identificações através de
fragmentos ósseos obviamente com a ajuda
da genética mas que mostram que
efetivamente vale a pena continuar a
investigar em e depois de a frança ea
trabalhar em equipas interdisciplinares
brigada